hey we'll get to the intro and show
really quickly in a minute but please do
if you're subscribed hit the
notification bell click all
notifications because YouTube has
changed that a little bit and do
consider joining up at Mudd Club lot of
credit comm slush mug Club because we
are still demonetised and that's the
only way this show continues enjoy the
program
lahter with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
thirty Seconds God be with you alright
guys this is it twenty twenty move fast
and avoid getting those Community
Guidelines crying I want regular custom
famiglia it's an election year so use
those algorithms you're not sure if your
contents borderline err on the side of
caution we don't need any more channels
being bad keep the content clean
gentlemen see you on YouTube
and it gets worse videos what's your
name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's the sound so much to the editing
team you did a wonderful job on those
born there we have Jimmy Norton on the
show today oh I'm sorry I also I don't
know if you notice I have a new chair oh
but the thing is it's a great chair it's
far better because of my giant fat ass
and the lower back support yeah
they don't design [ __ ] and throw the
other four giant fat asses like mine but
the arms are the lower serving now I go
like this and I go and then it's just
really violence we did planted just we
have a lot to get yeah for those who are
saying are gonna catch up on everything
that happened when you were gone no but
some events so we are going to talk
about Elizabeth warrants and she's
looking at the front runner or Tata five
or four biggest campaign wise boldest
title at five yeah because it around it
looks good before I move on regardless
of what you think regarding her policy
or any of the policies I guess from the
people who remain in the DNC field who
do you view as a more honest genuine
candidate Bernie or Elizabeth Warren
because the two have kind of been going
at it
we have quarterblack Garrett if a black
guy like Star Wars which is you do what
you know wait is here G Morgan Jr what's
the one of the day one of the day is 10
at the pundit 10 at the pundit and it
young ditz almost 10 it the pundit
tenant tenant under punt but it has an
owl on it it does doesn't make any sense
at all
it's very good I have shows you that
wine snobs are affected and my
half-asian lawyer bill Richman is here
glad to be here are you glad to be I am
so glad I don't put a lot to get you
news is what do you guys will have a
good break yeah anything special happen
you know stop man didn't have to change
Gerald for a couple weeks that was nice
I thought were suck yeah well I could
have told you that I'm glad everyone
came and crept with some interesting
anecdote
but first Christmas happens Constantine
I hate you first probe on Julian Castro
is actually set to endorse Elizabeth
Warren Mego now ladies and gentlemen
please join me in welcoming secretary
Julian Castro now I'm not sure if on
YouTube we're allowed to send Mexican
him I don't know but if it's preceded by
in Mexico hmm I think we're okay yeah
more coverage that is fired but I think
she worked for the Castro campaign so
you know it was over there's justice
leading the news of course for those who
haven't been following Vince Vaughn was
seen with Donald Trump at a college
football national championship all the
kinds of controversy the actor was seen
chatting laughing in a private box even
shook his hand Wow
most of you may have just seen the clip
but we've actually obtained some
exclusive audio and when you take it in
context now it looks like mr. Vaughn
actually had some serious policy
proposals for example listen I know
you're busy I want you to let that
simmer for a little bit okay percolate
on that and I wanted to get back to me
all right
more constitutes less crime okay okay
thanks you know what used to be drawn
upon a crime for looking so good am i
right it's a good point
they didn't make a valid point and he
stayed on message that he did it's
almost important methinks me smells a
2024
perhaps in Vince Vaughn Shapiro ticket
oh yeah we would talk that a second you
want to be the top ticket but I think
tiresome if that's okay to you but it's
not okay to me but it's okay but maybe
it's not okay listen I understand you're
some great ideas kid let's put that in
the back pocket and go on down make some
bad decisions maybe the good decisions
okay out here on my yarmulke American
history don't judge their way to love
each other right with only a few weeks
to go before the Iowa caucus you know I
don't know if you've been seeing as
things are starting to really heat up
very hot yeah we discussing more about
Warren and Bernie and a little bit
though it appears that it was the
Sanders campaign that fired the first
shot so this comes from Politico
volunteers have been given a script to
now refer to Warren as an elitist who is
quote bringing no new basis into the
Democratic Party volunteers have been
getting I don't want to say underhanded
but they've been playing some I wouldn't
call it necessarily fair ball we've
obtained some audio from one of these
volunteers calls I believe only I would
say volunteer might be a bit of a
stretch
there is no question you need to keep
your powder dry Bernie you lose the
Boise's oh my gosh this is just I it's
one of those fights where you're just
hoping for a rocky three double knockout
exactly and then Ivan Drago kills her
trainer I don't know that would be well
be different awesome and Schultz turning
to Entertainment
the man who portrayed Superman on
Hollywood Boulevard a lot of you know
him he died this week coroner said that
he suffocated to death
unfortunately inside of a clothing
donation bin while high on
methamphetamine terrible way to go so it
turns out this Superman's kryptonite was
meth yeah yeah rocky sucks and everyone
for some reason has it one of those meth
what is it with Superman he has all the
powers in the world except around
kryptonite which is from his home planet
so apparently everyone on Krypton just
act like they have AIDS they have no
power everyone on earth has kryptonite
something yeah it's like a charm brave
like kryptonite like garlic on the
bright side this Superman didn't live
long enough to star in horse camp so
there's good for home there's good yeah
everybody has your blessings spoiler
alert you got to do the title is exactly
the film we're expecting a zag it is
about a camp with a horse okay not
horses yeah horse and teri hatcher
cameos so have you been following the
Royal drama yes
you guys still have Emperor's and such
right oh yeah absolutely we very much
love the monarchs so the Queen has
agreed on a period of transition for
Prince Arian and Meghan Markel's comes
from CNN comes after the couple's
bombshell announcement that you know
they wanted to step back from their
roles as senior members of the royal
family and the Queen said that she is
relieved to finally be rid of this black
stain on the House of Windsor so that
they can get back to doing what they do
best
horrific inbreeding they're excited
about it doesn't even connect it's not
even May is he growing that extra here
to like donate to someone is there like
this nice that's a birthmark oh well I
should say it's not functional oh so we
just refer to it as a birthmark with
Prince Charles you're like oh my gosh
someone has to marry that guy and then
you realize you know people are with him
for his money
and then the really disgustingly
revoltingly ugly man picks Camilla just
stop the inbreeding with what you know
right I think the flipper kids would be
more appealing so it's been announced
that Harry and Megan um they're going to
live part time in Canada do you guys
know about that away anybody that you
know well you know I did it for 18 years
so thanks prime minister justin trudeau
he said that tax payers may or may not
have to fund their security detail
though the Prime Minister feels that
most Canadians would be supportive he
says that's and that's because most
Canadians Justin Trudeau speaks with our
[ __ ]
I thought those because they liked
people in blackface that as well but I
guess quoting page six in the source is
not what it used to be shallow grave
like that of a serial killer okay this
is a strange the ones that steal killers
dig their graves are not shells with
their own graves the serial killers now
with the others strange story here I'm
carrying this
we're gonna talk about Elizabeth and
Bernie a little bit hold your horses we
just have a lot of content we wanted to
get out and like it you know hit fast
forward and I don't blame you
after sitting down for a caricature this
next one a man was a man robbed the
caricature artist but left the drawing
on really easel that's my people
that's amazing
luckily the police responded and the
suspect was quickly detained apprehended
so yeah he were like the guy on the
streamlet plays the cello he's gonna
main things cello see their violin or
cello or abusing small children many of
course are still reeling from that you
know the Hanukah tragedy stabbing from
over the break for which the suspect has
been charged now with six counts of
attempted murder and in an update the
suspect said that he is still hopeful
but that after murdering a bunch of Jews
it's hard to find a good lawyer oh my
god Vince Vaughn yes Curtis tolerable
he's off alive and passed the bar yet
but I think fifth time's the charm
here's what I'm saying I think I can go
I think that we can pair up together and
then he make some magic happen maybe you
would make Matt you haven't maybe don't
take this let this go in your back
pocket we'll come back to it Uncle Sam's
on the Pricer net story stick tagging I
don't know how to put this but this was
this was the number-one trend one day
you saw it quarter yet black Garrett
yeah and how I you know I don't want to
be that guy who says that this will
destroy all of Western civilization from
within mm-hmm probably well how does
actress I guess Gwyneth Paltrow and
Google entrepreneur and by the way my
wife I got in the shower that's goop you
guys know that go I'll show her Brandis
booth and I get into the shower and I
see goop body scrub no and I'm like I
paid $75 for shampoo
right with a little bit of baking soda
in it oh my gosh that's terrible okay
Gwyneth Paltrow is now selling a candle
that if you have children get him out of
the room
she says smells like her vagina again
this comes from page six I'm reading a
direct quote the candle which is
literally called smells like my vagina
lists for $75 but is currently sold out
Wow yeah it's already completely sold
out all right listen you you do you but
I don't like it we go now live to ex
boyfriend Brad Pitt's unboxing review
with the box what's in the box
[Music]
become it Brad become vagina Kendall no
no that was that was Kevin's fate I know
I'm just like no Kevin Spacey's not as
good as the anything at this point true
he's at the bottom of the barrel
probably with a few boys finally they're
in the barrels in barrels were either
judge who among us has not committed
sexual assault in a barrel Cory Booker
in case you didn't know dropped out of
the presidential race in a message to
supporters he said he will carry this
fight forward he just won't be doing it
this year and here at louder with
Crowder I'd like to wish of course
senator Booker I mean listen these
people they're they're worthy
competition I don't wish him any ill
will wish senator Booker well in his
future endeavors as far as his campaign
goes it's time to close up shop
the New York Times pointed out yesterday
that when this Democratic primary
started it was the most racially diverse
in history yet now the top tier
candidates are all men and all white
time too
endings and beginners are ending and
beginning
[Music]
I love seeing on Twitter when someone
says I'm gay and I say so what does it
matter if I am so be it I hope you are
not voting for me because you were
making the presumption that I'm straight
I have an incredible girlfriend I have
this incredible girlfriend she's an
incredible girlfriend please don't try
to like you know put more pressure on
I'm afraid that rosario Dawson joins
boyfriend Cory Booker at a premiere and
he tweeted actually I joined her were
you ever called white boy I want to say
no actually I want to translate that
into Spanish dirty I found that out now
I appreciate the comments of my
colleagues this is about the closest
I'll probably ever have in my life to an
I am Spartacus moment do you know what
is in a Marguerite clearly I do now
because it was one of my biggest
mistakes in the campaign gee not a lot
on some policy issue
[Music]
how do you say in Spanish if Lex Luthor
[ __ ] the hodgetwins so we're down we're
down to only 1800 left I believe in it
be okay yeah yeah
count them slowly yeah I'm not gonna be
covered I will cover the debates once
it's down to the top three and I do
think we're gonna be doing another Oscar
stream this year so tell us the costumes
you want to see let's get to Elizabeth
Warren's
top five campaign lies I think this is
important we've done it with some other
candidates especially since right now
Elizabeth Warren is the front please be
Elizabeth Warren I want to see the
election between Donald Trump and
Elizabeth Warren so badly easiest out is
that way horse can be hilarious below
and let me know the reason why is Donald
Trump doesn't really apologize no he
doesn't waddle back and he's already
gone to Pocahontas I know that's gonna
be hilarious so I'm very curious as to
where he takes it from there it's his
rule is he's always pressing forward
like I assume that campaign is going up
some posters that includes scalping yeah
it's gonna like walk up and give her a
Snuggie schmuck Elizabeth I think it's
gonna be great though I really do I
really want to see him who do you guys
think is the easiest from the beat
Warren yeah yeah yeah it's hands-down
Obama connection too much old I think
Warren kind of had that Hillary they do
it where they're seasoned artists out
and but he's the easiest one on paper to
beat yeah buddy do you know he'll be
dead so again your question I didn't say
I don't take any joy in it I know you
die it's a song because that wouldn't be
biblical no we wouldn't do that moment
of silence for Bernie okay okay let's
give you some context here line number
five and this is a big one the lie that
Elizabeth Warren perpetuate out there
that Bernie senator Sanders said that
a woman couldn't win the presidency for
people out there who don't know I think
most of you at this point there was a
story that that went out and I remember
I was sort of not reading a ton of news
Christmas through New Year's and so is
coming back in I understand what it's
like for you guys it's tough to digest
it's like drinking from a firehose and
so you read it and sometimes you assume
why would someone lie about that and
then you realize Chris Cuomo that makes
sense now you connect the dots right
yeah so the story out there and I was on
CNN that's where I originally read it
and was covered everywhere was that
Bernie Sanders told Elizabeth Warren or
made a phone call and said that a woman
couldn't win the presidency there were
no sources provided by the way no
legitimate sources it was denied
outright by the Sanders campaign okay so
I want to be clear to set that context
claim no corroboration no source denied
by the Sanders campaign and then the CNN
moderators pulled this move live with
Bernie Sanders you're saying that you
never told senator Warren that a woman
could not win the election that is
correct senator Warren pretty clear what
did you think when senators and roots
and errs told you a woman could not win
disagreed back pocket full of anthrax
I understand a lot of people out there
were kind of Bernie pros listen I
understand where you're coming from
where you feel like the deck is stacked
against Bernie from the Democratic
establishment maybe your lead-in spirit
or confirmed do you see him laugh too
and he said we heard he's like yeah
we go again all right so this is
important after the debate Elizabeth
Warren confronted Bernie and but this
seems so staged
because CNN recorded it but they had the
right camera angle and the mic still
going and then they aired this footage
[Applause]
let's not do it right now
wanna have that discussion we'll have
that discussion you called me like you
told me that's classy
Bernie for that one the only one we will
I don't here's the thing I think that
he's wrong but I do think there's a he's
a godless man who's trying to do the
right thing now in his mind the right
thing involves killing babies and
stealing people's money I get that true
but he did try and take the high road
yeah there which I appreciate you trying
to dodge what's obviously an attack but
just think of that rule think of that
rule according to Warren you know they
just made up something that's an
indictment on someone's character and
when he corrects the record he's
accusing her of being a liar it'd be
like me saying hey Gerald remember when
you said that you were you were a rapist
and you said no it's not really
Terrapins that's not true and then I
said why did you call me a liar on my
own show exactly yes wonder why did you
get the moderator to ask me if it was
true and then I know it was true in the
question right you called me a lot you
call me a liar national television Coca
hanta so and of course again kekekeke
claims that he's never said that I
believe him lest you think that I have
no reason or context to believe that
Bernie Sanders has a track record of
saying that a woman could be president
the real issue is not whether you're
black or white whether you're a woman or
a man in my view a woman could be
elected president of the United States
the real issue is whose side are you on
again I don't like Bernie Sanders but I
do appreciate truth can we say woman can
become president and also he looks like
the scientist and a weird Nickelodeon
yes for a kid like
evaporation precipitation inflation find
a barber or be a mathematician I'm one
of the two that was young Bernie I know
that was burning my nose 40 years ago
when he was 90 it's fine wow I really
thought it was the same guy if someone
out there can do this I will send you a
free mug membership if you can somehow
make it look like Bernie was in the
live-action Cats
yes see that as the ball of yarn they're
playing this is not a binding contract
not at all but you should still do it
anyways it will watch it this is
something else that really bothered with
Elizabeth Warren they were after this
some people are coming out accusing
Bernie Sanders of being as bad as the me
to rapist crowd the rapist defender
truck yeah so a prolific and
well-respected journalist and I hate
this because sometimes you'll get this
on even on CNN or shows like The Young
Turks or like Trevor Noah though the
people and they bring up a tweet from
some random person with two followers
and it's just two other eggs so this
journalist writes for place Washington
Post New York Times GQ gentlemen's
quarterly for the uninitiated Julia LOF
she tweeted I want to make sure I get it
correct still thinking about the warned
Bernie squabble and I have a question to
people who have accused Warren of lying
isn't the lesson of hashtag me too in
the last few years that we believe women
and don't call them liars
I thought the lesson which by the way
was ill founded was that we always
believed women who make accusation
accusations of rape but I don't believe
that but now you're saying we have to
believe all women on everything no I
think that was the lesson well I think
Julia's being intellectually honest
about what the plan was
yeah it's always been right no no
rebuttals no kind of evidence no trials
no questions no investigation no even
raising the eyebrow no you can't do
anything it must be just accepted and
she's finally at least
admitting that that's what it's all
about yeah yeah and it didn't just stop
it right like the the lesson was don't
just believe we had too many cases of
people saying oh that actually never
even happened and that was just a
complete smear against somebody like the
lesson is prove your allegations if you
can please the lesson was verified but
now the extract we've expanded that from
rape culture which isn't a real thing
right to anything a woman says ever yeah
that is so disturbed she writes this by
the way for GQ gentlemen's quarterly I
am sad yeah your subscriptions are
shrinking is ready for gentle hey what's
in this week's edition month's edition
of GQ is it how do wear suits how to
pull off a skinny tie no way men are
pieces of pieces of pieces and there's
an ad for Armani Cologne that's my
quarterly ass-kicking for being a man
I'll read this manga haché GQ that's
what gentlemen want to read about all
men being liars okay so that's why I
never felt let's look at the Elizabeth
Warren's track record on the truth kind
of outside of Bernie Sanders yeah
number four soon was a big one a lot of
people may have forgotten about this she
claimed that she was fired for being
pregnant yeah so she contract was nude
for the next year and I was all set to
go but I was pregnant at the time wasn't
showing yet about two months later when
I was visibly pregnant about six months
along the principal called me in and
said that he wished me luck
but he'd be more comfortable having
someone else in that job and he was
going to hire someone else for the job
and that was it I lost my job a
component of that may be true in that I
too would be comfortable hiring someone
else but it has nothing to do that yeah
you are with child no you would be more
comfortable with anyone else and it has
nothing to do with your miracle of
creating life
did you notice when you've watched that
she didn't get the memo on how to lie
I'll get to why none of this is true she
was claiming that she was fired from a
teaching job for being pregnant
the first thing they ready like if you
go google signs that someone is lying
and this is very rudimentary and it's
not often true and it's very easy to
beat this right if you're a liar but you
didn't even do that the first thing is
they look away they looked and they
often look to the left and she is
consistently as she's saying that
looking down and to the left down into
the leg it's like she took corners the
instructions how to throw people off the
scent that you're lying it wasn't when I
was a kid and I got him she's not even
capable of lying when I was a kid I got
a magic set I immediately felt like I
know how to do magic now hey Dad where's
your car and I would Palm it but you
would see it in the back of my hand like
look where's your car yeah look at it
what are you doing the Star Trek sign I
don't know I was so bad at palming it
that's Elizabeth Warren with lying that
was a long way around but you understand
it school records content by the way is
there some kind of liability there a
half-asian bill if someone says I was
fired for being pregnant and there's
proof that that's not the case well I
mean it gets to a kind of a common claim
such as defamation right you're you're
saying this school district this
individual did something fall did
something wrong that thing we were doing
their job wrong you've accused them of
something negative but it's false that's
a basic defamation claim yeah there you
go if I was a principal and if that
person is still alive sue by the way
okay seems like she's don't listen to
Gerald he's not a lawyer if you listen
to Gerald the next sound you hear will
be the bars clanking as you remain there
there's nothing wrong with her scent it
is raining so hard right now that the
roof is that do you hear that
I do well that's I pointed I'm like hey
one of those rain sticks that you would
get to read was it like rain forest cafe
right next to the stage that kind of
acted like a relay over fries
school records here's important they
show by the way that not only was a
contract unanimously renewed she was not
fired she resigned that's different yeah
she was I that's what I almost predict
no she won
fired sheera time unless you think that
these former employers are lying it
actually tends to match up with the
unofficial testimony of you guessed it
worked it was in a public school system
but I worked with the children with
disabilities and I did that for a year
and then that summer I actually didn't
have the education courses so I was on
an emergency certificate that was called
and I went back to graduate school and
took a couple of courses in education
and said I don't think this is going to
work out for me and I was pregnant with
my first baby so I had a baby and stayed
home for a couple of years she looks
older back then terrible when you rebut
yourself I have no idea imagine being
the person who who has anyway I don't
want it I can't get her name she's
unattractive so yeah there's not a
definitive claim sure it's not opinion
it is yeah I find you repulsive but not
in here we have some people in the
studio here who you know take what they
can get threading the needle carefully
which we will not do the notification
bell if you are on YouTube hit all
notifications because there's another
step right now better hit the bell and
then there's gonna say all you want to
go to all seeking all the notifications
get the stream maker here's you don't
get the live stream if you don't hit all
okay and of course we have new videos
that go up every day at 8:00 or 9:00
Eastern and of course that's why we do
ask that you join my club letters credit
accomplishment club there's a lot more
content there the entire blaze catalog
because these rules keep changing that's
how we stay in touch with you line
number three she claimed that her
children attended public schools there
needs to be a little bit of context here
a woman told Elizabeth Warren that their
children had different opportunities
because warns children probably went to
private school
and elizabeth warren immediately
corrected are saying that they attended
public schools we don't have a fine
choice
okay now that seems pretty cut and dry
yeah does meaning a lie here's the thing
i don't have you know that's about john
edwards actually my wife had read the
book i don't know how many books are on
john edwards it seems to be once you get
to the point where he's making a sex
tape
with a pregnant lady while his wife has
cancer in the hospital you close the
book and go oh he's the villain done
yeah you think he used to buy like
Armani suits like expensive Armani
Versace's Hugo Boss ketone suits and
then he would take out the tag and so in
JC Penney's really yes he would do that
because he wanted to seem like he was of
the people this is what the Democrats do
it's like the fake rappers getting shot
in the face stories to have street cred
they're just like you their kids went to
public schools look he Shops at JCP I
think because the men are the people but
I don't understand this why is it bad if
your kids went to a private school yeah
why is it bad to wear in Armani suit at
least President Trump kind of owns it
he's the one guys I guess he goes out
there and really rich and the middle
class needs some help that you can have
both he couldn't deny it at this point
though no I don't think way too far past
embellished it yes I will be the first
trillionaire and bi will be mean and so
her kids did go to public school for
like a semester I couldn't find out how
long but for the majority of their
school careers they went to private
schools with tuitions ranging from
seventeen thousand to forty thousand
dollars a year well yeah oh my gosh look
I don't call me crazy I want some guys
who maybe could do it in their own life
to be able to go do it for the country
like I don't want somebody's like I am
just like you I couldn't make anything
out of my life at all but now I'm
running for office and I'll do a better
job when there's more money at stake
right there like it's not my candidate
guys we've seen look a OC has really
changed
I think we should go generic tail as a
model let the model see if it'll work
out just like communism do you think in
ten years from now
Elizabeth Warren is just going to be
like a swaddled baby yes to be present
callback to the reverse aging I'm sure
her Unitarian Church could use her in
the nativity scene luckily enough to
have played all the roles Mary Joseph
the baby the donkey that I mean the
whole thing what am I gonna play this
year as I drink my beer I don't know you
can you want Balthazar's available all
right number two she claimed that she
was too poor to afford college now this
is important because again it doesn't
match up with her other claims ray Jill
Biden desk with this Elizabeth Warren
claimed that college wasn't affordable
in her day and that her parents couldn't
afford a college application let alone
putting her through college by the time
I graduated from high school my folks
couldn't afford a college application
much less to send me off to four years
of university so like a lot of Americans
I don't have a straight path story she
say I don't have a straight pant story I
don't know I thought she was talking
about boot cut that straight cut now
here's here's the truth her parents
didn't put her through college because
she went to George Washington University
on a scholarship so a little detail that
yeah and then she dropped out how did
she get in without an application well
this is conjecture but she was forced to
sell her body Oh
the news organization we've heard of
here first tell everybody and send for
you she was a prostitute and actually
her pimp was approaching say sire an
interdimensional vampire Keebler Elf
[Laughter]
Pepperidge Farm and pepperidge and big
Keebler and mr. Christie he was beside
sour someone with an acne plunger she
dropped out of college to get married
and end up going to another public
college for $50 a semester which she
herself tweeted out I want to make sure
I get this right so I go to mine on
prompter don't you love this iPad tech I
got my degree thanks to a quality public
College where tuition was just $50 a
semester that kind of opportunity
doesn't exist for students today again I
don't care that she got a scholarship I
don't care that she went to a community
college I think that's actually a good
point that $50 is Mester there's a way
to make certain colleges affordable but
the problem is we have two contradicting
narratives here first you have the one
where she was a poor child who's just a
poor black child who couldn't afford
college then you have a second that it
was so easy in her day to go to college
because it was so cheap as opposed to
today and it depends on who she's
talking to and what bill of goods she
needs to sell and that's what bothers me
yeah and how foolish would it be if
you're so poor that your parents can't
pay for the application fee and you are
blessed with a scholarship that you then
drop out and run away from that
scholarship to just run off and get
married you can't get married and stay
in school and try to make a better life
for your kids right you just took a huge
risk you're lucky it worked out Foca
Hadas I don't like that you said that
I'm sorry Trump said it you have to bow
Pocahontas I'm fine with I draw the line
at offensively puns
look it worked
are you already a dad no oh no ok line
number one I think you could have seen
this coming
I'm sorry I get it but actually we did a
whole segment on this and we had to
remove it because I was wearing the
socialist a t-shirt from the Asian bill
knows that but it's available at my club
so it's a little more in depth and Jimmy
Norton is coming up after this which
mean the Irishman will be talking about
the film being nominated for the Academy
Award line number one her dua what's the
word engine is it's something a lot of
Indian is offensive wait till you see
the clip oh and then I have I have a
microfiber cloth for the egg on your
face she's repeatedly used the
supportive as opposed to street cred of
being Native American as a talking point
and just as a refresher on the campaign
trail my father's parents said
absolutely not you can't marry her
because she's part Cherokee and she's
part Delaware my Toller had high
cheekbones like all of the Indians do oh
she said it not which I they all have
high cheek every one of them all of them
all of them no one else apparently no
one entirety no I mean countries by the
way she didn't just dabble in like oh
I'm part Native American she wrote a
cookbook about it she went out this year
she was speaking on reservations she's
not she's not the DNA test that she took
to prove which is remarkable to me this
just shows you the ego on these people
like someone should have advised her
this was a bad idea she took a DNA test
to prove that she was Indian her words
not mine
and it actually showed that she may have
less Indian blood than your average
non-indian American a whopping 1 in 1000
24th huh native by the way for reference
here's my 23andme I am about as much
sub-saharan
[ __ ] the show and I just sort of drop
in n-bombs I wrote a book about the
plight of blossom and the history of
slavery and there's my 23 to me it
sounds absurd it is exactly the same the
percentage is entirely comparable here's
what's really sinister about it though
not that someone lied about their
heritage that's kind of crappy but you
know maybe you do it at dinner parties
to make yourself interesting once the
conversations sort of reached its end
with reverse aging gimmick here's the
deal
she is claimed repeatedly that even
though she's part Indian Native American
she's never benefited she's never used
it I never used my family tree to get a
break but that a bit I never used it to
advance my career
hmm question the book deal powwow ciao
[Music]
figment of our imagination doesn't it
doesn't because she she actually had to
give the advance back as a book sold so
poorly Oh sold or not but just assumed
it had nothing to do with it that's
because she was a woman
oh so she'll never win yeah or you're
not or no one's reading yeah and even
now no one's reading the appeals of
gender-bending so what was it term turf
anyway that happened during the break I
don't wanna get into it not only did she
sell a Native American cookbook she used
her Native American identity to land a
teaching job at Harvard hmm and their
law review I have a lawyer here hailed
her as being the first woman of color
hired they're getting a little loose
with the terminology aren't we yeah yeah
colors no no black is the absence of
color what is all the colors and the
colors like paint you're wrong white is
the absence I think all of them is wrong
yeah I think you're better at lawyering
thank you I think none of you are good
at the color palette no I'm partially
colored line so I color wheel here just
like for every single democratic debate
now imagine if for some if we claim that
this show was the first online
late-night podcast show with a host of
color because with my sub-saharan
African as Elizabeth what lest you doubt
me by the way it's absurd that's why
again I can't miss the share the lower
back support is on my coccyx I'm the
thing on that on the armrest because a
black woman told me one time she goes oh
you gotta get old booty I said what does
that mean it sounds like sexual
harassment but you piqued my interest
[Laughter]
I'm still with you
we caught a ghetto booty and I said oh
well I can't say that before I could
even at all trying to like white-guilt
my way out of it she's went true story
with a hotel in Dallas I was with I
can't that was with another host and he
was just like that was really
uncomfortable wasn't it yeah it's kind
of rapey all right this is important
because we know people will say well
Donald Trump lies granted he does okay
no one is perfect but the difference
here is that and this is just my opinion
and I want to hear what you think Donald
Trump exaggerates actions Yeah right
Donald Trump what he has a tendency to
do there's difference between lying like
a sinister lie and being a bit of a
[ __ ] artist yeah and anyone who's
ever worked in sales I mean you know
that you're selling a car this is the
best car on the lot right it's a
stereotype for a reason he will
exaggerated right the the length of his
successes and then he'll diminish maybe
the depths of his failures right so
Donald Trump yeah I get it in other
words he might be worth three billion
was seven billion okay no excuse me
seven billion loss I'm at the Deutsche
Bank and says you were three billion
they are fake news not a news outlet
it's just a Jewish Count name and they
know the minute you like Donald Trump
may have been and a good athlete in
school but he I was the best athlete in
school okay Rudy wishes he with me like
Rudy wasn't even that good of an athlete
because he wasn't me that's what I said
so he exaggerated s' actions and it'll
diminish his failures maybe hey how many
times have you filed bankruptcy never
well okay I get it your businesses fell
bankruptcy not you personally so I think
that that is different sort of
exaggerating or maybe embellishing
actions versus Elizabeth Warren who
misrepresents who she is
she misrepresents who she's at the PERT
make no mistake we all laughed at Rachel
Dolezal remember the the fake black and
double AC P Sideshow Bob hair it's no
different than one and here's the thing
this is so important when people out
there when you read you look at box you
look at BuzzFeed you look at Salon you
look at CNN they say your race your
gender it is your identity it defines
who you are that's very different from
saying hey here's my pocketbook too hey
this is who I am this is what this is
the makeup of my soul and that is
entirely a lie simply to pander for
votes that's more off-putting to me more
off-putting to me than saying I could
write a check for a billion dollars is
someone lying about being engine I don't
know you comment tell me Jim Norton
right after this stay tuned
[Music]
all right pressure on it come on tell us
how to fix you
give it to me come on give it to me
[Music]
black rifle coffee black rival coffee
calm slash Crowder if you enter in the
promo code Crowder you get a discount
code 20% off your first order listen
great company veteran-owned they give a
portion of their profits to veteran Orry
but you guys don't care about that it's
better coffee just try it black rifle
coffee calm slash Crowder they're a
great sponsor they're the balls to
support this show and the coffee is
genuine put it side by side with your
house of the Maxwells and your joyful
and let me know what you think black
rifle coffee calm slash Crowder glad to
be with them nada with proud of shop
comm is now selling baseball team in red
and get yours at ladder with quite a
shop calm today Hagar just so you know
Stephen moved the taping back thirty
minutes all right so great yeah thanks
for the heads up
[Music]
hey Garrett we actually are gonna need
different brownie
at least what you do online is your
business protect your business with
expressvpn new sponsor to the show
expressvpn go to expressvpn dot-com
slash Crowder right now you'll get an
extra three months of expressvpn for
free listen if you watch it you probably
spend a lot of time online and you want
your data to be 100% your business you
want it to be private expressvpn reached
out to us we've used them in the past I
think actually we did the tulsi gabbard
video where we looked at the search
results we used expressvpn on some of
our search results to try different
locations not only are they reliable not
only is their service better than the
others out there if you compare it to a
cost reward ratio but they didn't have a
security breach and not tell you for a
year as has happened with some competing
VPNs you can do your own research lest I
get sued expressvpn comm / Crowder what
you do online is your business keep it
your business you get three months free
[Music]
see now I'm really self-conscious with
the dancing because they're our next
guests we were just talking about it
during the commercial break
number one time he was talking about
someone who shall remain nameless but I
know that our next guests who fight
against it at Jim Norton Jim Norton calm
it is it is Jim Norton it is it is one
Jim Norton where he said oh that guy's a
dope he said in cornball and he said it
and I realized that he meant it like I
wish I hated anything as much as he
hated this in cornball but it was
bizarre to me to hear the term cornball
and Ranford to represent such disdain
you know he's a co-host of a UFC
unfiltered podcast DeGeneres is on
Netflix if you haven't seen it yet he's
in the recent Martin Scorsese the
Irishman from Jim Norton how are you sir
I'm great party how are you doing you
know what what the cornball thing like
because you use that a lot it's like the
ultimate diss because for some reason it
feels good coming out this is a football
it's like it's a couple of syllables and
it feels right it's gonna hard sound at
the beginning and it's really
deconstructing like anyone who thinks
they're hip if you're like oh you're a
cornball let's say ah there's no
rebounding from being yeah I suppose I
guess as a comedian that sort of matters
because you want to be hip in the
nightclubs with the kids and if someone
says you're a cornball okay then I'm not
gonna be the next Dane Cook yeah it just
sucks
yes it sucks to be a cornball that's
true and you had Plus you had a lot of
black friends I did growing up yeah and
that black guys calling you corny was
the harshest thing because you want to
just be like a white guy who's accepted
by black guys and the thought of is cool
or at least thought of is not in corny
right vehicle corny was just I don't
know why that was a humiliating insult
1985 right President Joe Biden puts it
on his resume so yeah he's proud of
President and corny so yeah we have a
bunch to get to here first off let me
ask you this did you ever think that you
are going to be in the film nominated
and arguably the favorite or at least
certainly up there for Best Picture for
Academy Award no it's so funny man like
to be involved with that
in fact I made the file I didn't know I
made the cut until the night before I
was at the Comedy Cellar and Ray Romano
came in he's a great job in the movie
and I'm like because I was trying to get
tickets to the premiere and I was like
they're not getting me tickets so I'm
not gonna be able to go so I'm not in
the movie I was spiraling mentally and
then Ray told me like no you're in it
and you did good and then I got tickets
and went and saw it and I was happy with
how it came out you know like watching
myself is always a nightmare right but
seeing this I'm like you know what they
showed more of it than I thought they
would like I didn't think they were
gonna show that much okay why is that
though were you just you just didn't
think that you and for those who don't
know you play Don Rickles on stage in
the you know a Joey Gallo was murdered
that night so that was actually it's
true to life he went in small wrinkles
at the Copa so I didn't know if it was a
critical enough scene to make it into a
movie that was cut from four hours to
3:30 I'm like if they have to cut five
more minutes for whatever reason right
that's probably not like a critical
scene like as much as you know some of
the other stuff they're doing with you
know Pacino but they Sebastian
references wrinkle what only Rickles can
make fun I guess right I guess
says he liked it because he left more
than I thought he would and that is
interesting to to note the white people
don't know they cut it from originally
four hours to three and a half hours or
as Peter Jackson calls that impossible
somebody's Final Cut Pro I'll take avid
at this point I don't think that man has
ever met a cut but now let me ask you
this playing Don Rick and I will say
your Don Rickles by the way was far more
consistent than Al Pacino's Jimmy Hoffa
very good performance but he was going
to Chicago New York Chicago that was the
only thing that he's like hi this is
Jimmy Hoffa
Jimmy I don't great film should everyone
if you're voting if you're members of
the Academy watching vote for this film
did you feel that there was a lot of
pressure I know it was a short scene but
Don Rickles in the realm of comedy that
gets a lot of pressure for someone to
portray them on screen you know it's
funny like the pressure I felt was
because I've been compared to him my
whole career but it's more about the
voice and the shape of the face because
I was like I like Rickles I understand
you use cornball hey what are you
cornball
he goes hey got that losing natural
it was never anything I aspired to be so
the fact that people would always say
that when they'll offered me the role I
didn't have to audition for it they said
Square says he watched like one or two
of my specials he's like if this guy can
do it so that even brought me and I had
a meeting with him when we just talk
comedy so I didn't represent to him I'd
do it I'll be the best Rickles you've
ever seen the fact that he offered it to
me removed pressure but then I walk in
the room it was I walked in the room and
it was literally just Scorsese De Niro
and patchy standing there talking was an
empty room except for those three in
between scenes and I'm like first of all
looking at Raging Bull I'm looking at
Goodfellas looking at casino right um
but I'm also looking at guys who knew
Rickles like Scorsese was friends with
him De Niro loved him
a penci loved him and did casino with
him so that was the intimidating part is
that you were doing Rickles in front of
people who like really were his friends
so that was a little nerve-racking and
did they give you any feedback or tips
like no no Don wouldn't say it this way
or were they pretty pretty well no they
were really great I mean do I had a
bunch of extra jokes and I just kind of
like old Rickles ones that I brought
just so the audience wouldn't get bored
cuz it was scripted so I was all these
other ones well I just start doing lines
and he just threw it to me so I was
lucky I had these wrinkles lines
prepared so uh you know what what was
your question I don't remember what the
question is but that brings back to the
next point which is how much of this
film how much of it is improvised
because there's a lot of sort of
conjecture surrounding that with Martin
Scorsese and I do imagine you know he
reuses a lot of the same actors I don't
know who I was just talking about with
this or about this what did I just say
my phrase I haven't done just have a
stroke anyway I was discussing this with
someone saying you know Quinton Tina
doesn't really use the same actors a
whole lot except for like Kurt Russell
and get Madsen Madsen and a couple of
those score says he kind of has his
regular crew and I will say this if you
see like Robert De Niro Al Pacino
brilliant actors but if you watch them
in interviews they seem sometimes like a
lot of actors a little uncomfortable in
their skin they're not necessarily the
quickest to the punch in an interview
they're a little more introspective so
I've always wondered how much of it is
really sticking to the script versus
giving you some room to play with it you
know it's funny I think that for them
this script it would I think they
probably respect his
whoever wrote the script but they
respected enough to stick with the
script right but I've done a couple of
small things like DeNiro open my special
where he introduces me and I wrote that
and I actually directed him in that
where he goes or what he does tell me to
do and it would meet him sat down his
assistants cleared the room I mean like
Jim and Bob will talk watching him like
he's just kind of the kind of it
meanders through it a little bit other
but like you're not sure reason to go
and then when the cameras on you're like
oh that's right
it's DeNiro right and you see when he
clicks in and he's doing it for real
like where it's natural you like this
guy is just a master at what he does and
that to me is they so they stick to the
script but I think he works through it a
little bit he'll go take after take
until he kind of has what he wants I've
watched him do that but he's pretty
comfortable making a mistake he's very
comfortable screwing up a line so that's
why he's so comfortable and doing what
he's doing like it was interesting to
watch him mess up a line and what we
called the comedian he was messing up a
line right but he didn't care he was
just like holler we don't like very
casual and comfortable yeah he's amazing
to watch a guy that good at what he does
yeah the only thing is just don't ask
him to go higher energy if he's at his
peak have you ever seen that that
outtake where he's doing a commercial
for like a PSA oh no and he says some
like so please give generously to
whatever the organization is and you
just hear off-camera yeah okay just a
little high energy no no excuse me that
was high energy I'm not selling cars
I'm not selling cars excuse me that was
high energy okay actual commercial
that's the take they used which was good
he has to started in order to see he is
a great instinct because he was spanking
me there was in the opening my special
he spanked me I didn't tell him until
the day we shot and then when I'm over
his lap like I laid on his lap and he
bare bottom spanked me and then he was
let's do one standing and that was the
tape we want abusing went for some
reason visually the energy of it like he
just knows what he's doing and if he
that's the energy you're getting that's
the energy yes yeah yeah at that point I
think it's more so just a personal
preference than a creative decision so I
think he's thankful to you he's forever
in debt something I a couple of things I
wanted to ask you about but I wanted to
get something a little little personal
in my experience with your content
recently and my friend who hadn't heard
a lot of your material but first this is
um let me ask you I guess Ricky Gervais
smart logs I'm sure you've talked about
this the monologue and the the backlash
and one thing that stood out to me the
most was people trying to Gaslight him
if you read a lot of the articles saying
Oh Ricky Gervais does what he does and
really it was old hat and by this point
it was tired I'm the one that's not this
that's not in sync with the reaction
that we saw from the outrage what were
your thoughts do you think a was it
funny and B did you think it was needed
it was amazing it's exactly what Ricky
was supposed to do like anybody doubts
that he's a real comedian like that's
exactly it was a Chris Rock at the
Oscars like that's what a real comic
does like he was first of all smart
enough to talk to the people at home who
are not celebrities ah Ricky didn't need
to do that type of monologue he could
have been playful and friendly but his
jokes were funny and he called them out
the way a comedian would call out an
audience member
whoa I didn't do that you did you did
for Hollywood again look I love actors
and so it's fun to watch what they do
but they get caught up in this babbling
at the rest of us how to live and they
don't do it like all this yappin about
diversity and they can't get a female
direct or not like you don't I mean like
right they they talk a good game and I
think Ricky capitalized on that mocked
them for it and stupid people like the
LA Times these fake woke idiots that
didn't appreciate the message he was
giving he was brilliant
he did exactly what he should have done
and any of them it didn't like it like
it ruined their night movies your
jackasses the content how about that how
about you stop you stop playing guys
like Ted Bundy and Edmund Kemper in
films and only play nice for all that's
right for you art is okay to do what you
want but for Ricky his art should be
tempered to make you comfortable oh well
I am glad to hear your opinion and you
know what that is interesting I said
they had this conversation with
more conservative relative of mine who
wouldn't watch this Commons like all
that was just too raunchy
I said you you watch Law & Order SVU
it's a severed raped body every night
like that is exploitation and by the way
they know there's exploitation not
necessarily pushing them like how many
episodes do you need if you're trying to
push a message like hey don't rape
bodies and leave them in the river no
you guys this is this is filth this is
basically a smut novel at this point and
it is funny with comedy how there is
always this whole like hey look that
should not be joked but it's almost like
as and I hate to say czar it is but as
as somebody who performs for a living
you use what's in the world you know how
come actors can use what's in the world
authors can use what's in the world they
never get accused of punching down they
never get accused of a prote but you
know they're comedian and you don't tell
a joke that somehow I'll completely uh
backs up somebody's ideology yeah you're
a terrible comedian who's doing it wrong
it's just silly and Ricky didn't pay
anything Ricky's great because he has a
lot to lose I mean he's at the top of
the heap he still is on Twitter saying
whatever he wants to say he still does a
monologue exactly the way he should do a
monologue I love him that he's one of my
favorite people that being said I will
acknowledge that I'm somewhat
hypocritical and that I think your
primary function obviously as a comedian
is or as an actor is to entertain and I
do think at the end of that he was off
book and some of those things weren't
necessarily punchlines it was just you
know what because you reacted this way
I'm gonna dig the knife in a little bit
and get offstage but I appreciated it
because I felt it was appropriate
because you were having fun at that it
seemed like was it Ray Romano and Adam
driver were the only ones who are
genuinely enjoying it wouldn't you if
you're an actor and your name pops up
you know if you know that your name is
gonna leave Ricky Gervais sees lips if
you hate it still just kind of that's
good and then call your agent and
haven't never work again dude I would I
this is why I love him so much because
I'm such a I'm such a coward Kim like
literally he looks at oh he's a guy from
Apple Tim Cook and he makes fun of the
sweatshops and he calls them out while
he's sitting in the room I would be so
like I love Apple can I have a MacBook
I I admired his ability to do it right
to their faces so he probably did turn
the night but that Weinstein joke was
great and then instead of like they did
what some other dumb audience would do
there what are you it's a good job you
know what I mean it was living life like
you're blind and you don't see with for
the bird box comparing it to working for
one see it was a good joke and it kind
of said what he wanted to say and they
reacted how he predicted they would
react yeah well specially the Epstein
thing you think that they will react
laughing and clap like ha ha ha ha we
hate Epstein especially he goes yeah you
were friends with him they're like oh no
no put some distance between yourself
and Epstein this is a lifeline yeah yeah
yeah they uh you're the priest Andrew
one when he said to hey mate you know
she's a little young about DiCaprio's
girlfriend yeah yeah I really enjoyed it
and I will go to a WebEx energy but I
really liked Dave Chappelle's Mark Twain
prize acceptance speech - because that
was he wasn't preaching at all but he
did get up and sort of talk about the
importance of comedy and and it really
was a political and saying every single
point of view is represented in comedy
but correctly from I feel almost like he
was saying hey every single point of
view should continue to be represented
in comedy I felt like that was the point
he was making a little bit because we've
seen people get cancelled now even in
stand-up clubs it happens well dave is
so I mean he's such a smart guy and he's
a great comic because he's such a
brilliant guy and the fact that he was
able to say it like it was a beautifully
packaged statement like if I had to say
something about comedy in today's
culture I would just want to kind of
write down what Dave said and repeat it
like the way he said it was so beautiful
and smart and it covered everything but
like you said it wasn't preachy it
wasn't over the top and it wasn't even
confrontational right it was just very
factual and Dave is so at the top of
everything we're all doing they can't
mess with him so what they'll do is
they'll ignore the poignancy of what he
said like they'll attack his jokes but
anybody who's against that point of view
what he said is so smart
you can't combat it yeah white man
saying it so they can't blame it on that
ah you know what I mean he's not a dumb
guy saying it so they can't blame an
done lack of until it he's a brilliant
guy so instead of confronting
realizing he's right they'll just
pretend they didn't hear it right okay
so we have to we're gonna go to a web
extended here for people who are not mug
Club members please do join up at my
club before we go Jim where's the best
place for people to find you I know they
can follow you Jim Norton calm but
you're doing lots of shows where should
they support you
the degenerates on Netflix I came out in
New Year's Eve I'm very happy with this
set and also I got dates coming up at
the Wilbur theater in Boston April 4th
there's a Late Show added April 3rd
Foxwoods in Connecticut or just Twitter
I'm around look at this he's doing
theaters no more strip malls I'll get
there one day
all right Jim Norton we're going to web
extended we'll wrap this up for people
who on the YouTube let us begin our
quest
[Music]
three-two-one
[Music]
don't eat too much I don't believe in
getting any
[Music]
don't have someone back home I've got my
wife and Wade's got his wife Brennan has
a sister and that's kind of weird but
let me from Arkansas bragging I don't
know what you do with your sister maybe
it's a on-again off-again definition of
it what the point is that this guy has
it worse than anyone else because he's
gonna be out here fighting and then so
fact just Lee chase down with some
German shepherds and a fire hose and a
theta parlor what's your home defense
plan when it comes to safety there's no
substitute for a quality firearm and if
you're a gun owner there's no
replacement for firearms legal
protection firearms legal protection
provides lawful gun owners an uncapped
legal defense program 24/7 emergency
hotline access to a network of over
2,500 experienced attorneys legal
education on firearm laws in your state
via our mobile app and plans to protect
you every step of the way if you are
involved in a self-defense ensign visit
firearms legal comm /lw see today
[Music]
that was a drowning dense right was
tentative I was nervous I was
apprehensive and insert other synonym
here of jumping into the water because
of my 1% sub-saharan African yeah it
does work against you and then I gained
confidence but I forgot that I was too
far from the surface and I died so thank
you Jim Norton thank you very much thank
you everyone of course you're the
wonderful team who put on this week's
great show we have a full week of shows
next week for those who are on Mudd Club
of course clips on YouTube and extended
exclusive interview with Jim Norton we
always very funny every now and then we
won't want to get into some topics that
may not be great for the tubing's use
yeah I just don't want I don't even want
to Auto recognize if I say the words
that's been moderators go and watch it
we can use the word I picture that's
what it's like at the opposite all right
so this is my kind of first clothes of
the week
here's one thing I wanted to talk about
a little bit and you may not like it
okay but one thing I think we look at
the depression epidemic in the country
and people considered an epidemic right
the mental health issues in this country
it is a little bizarre when you think
and I was wondering about this I was
talking with a relative over Christmas
break and that's what sort of forced me
to ponder if I may use the phrase or you
can kick my ass for using and I know
most only douches use the word ponder
and lovely I've never heard someone used
the term lovely unless they were trying
to lie about something well unless this
fruitcake is lovely I get it but it did
force me to think about this a little
bit you know we have what we refer to as
a depression as a mental health as a
hopelessness epidemic in this country
with young people and I'm not talking
about people who have clinical
depression or a chemical imbalance and I
don't want to get into that that's kind
of a number of people that have it's
been relatively stable but people when
polled young people who have a feeling
of hopelessness and believe that their
opportunities will be fewer than their
parents this is the first generation to
feel that way
and it's bizarre that they feel that way
when we live in the most marvelous time
throughout all of humanity we have more
tools and resources at our disposal and
people are depressed or they're looking
at the world as bleak and this comes
from a simple concept and I'm not saying
anything new necessarily I'm sure Jordan
Peterson has talked about this and
people like Jack o willing who've been
on the show me sure I've talked about
this at some point all satisfaction all
accomplishment all pleasure comes from
pain and so I don't think we have a
problem in this country of people who
are in too much pain I think we have a
problem right now not in this country
but across the globe of people who don't
experience enough pain and that's why
they don't experience the elation it's
why they don't experience the Bliss of
overcoming pain let me explain it to you
a little bit let me give you a little
bit of context let's say you're hungry
okay you're hungry and when you eat I
bring you a steak dinner I don't know I
bring you a bunch of Singapore rice
noodles take your pick it's satisfying
the pleasure comes from the fulfillment
of a required need right the pain of
being hungry the discomfort of being
hungry leads to the pleasure the
satisfaction of now being full now let
me ask you this how many of you out
there experience pleasure or
satisfaction from eating food when
you're already stuffed if I bring you
another steak dinner if I bring you
another plate of rice noodles maybe it
starts getting a little less appetizing
I bring you a third one and then I force
you to eat it guess what that's no
longer Pleasant let's use another
example you go to the gym you sweat
you're jogging in the rain where it's
cold right it's winter a lot of people
out there you've been sending in your
fitness videos and kind of how you been
losing weight over the break
appreciate it keep it up you get home
and what happens after the jog in the
rain how good does that shower feel
everyone knows that hot shower
it feels amazing it comes that happiness
stems from the fulfillment of of a need
being met discomfort pain cold it's 20
degrees I'm wet I need to get into a
shower I need to warm up and to clean
myself and
it's bliss now let's change that how
many of you out there and there's
nothing wrong with this I'm guilty of
this sometimes on the weekend how many
of you have just had a comfortable
pajama day where you lay around and do
nothing sometimes you may not even
shower on those days I know particularly
women I don't know what it is but men in
my experience tend to be more meticulous
about showering and women can get away
with it because they don't smell the
same way men do after one day anyway
these are things that you learn when
you're married takes a couple of years I
did not realize this you don't have to
shower every single day and you don't
smell like a crotch swamp good for you
but how many of you have had days where
you haven't gone out and done anything
active you haven't really you haven't
soiled yourself and I know that that'll
be used here you take a shower that day
do you get the same feeling of bliss
from the shower if you come in from the
cold it's really just sort of well I
guess I'll do this it's not the same
because it's not a need that's being met
there isn't the discomfort the
displacement the pain of having a need
not yet met so I want to tell you this
if you find yourself maybe looking at a
bleak life or what you see is a hopeless
outcome a lot of people think okay I've
got it I've got to find a way to make
myself comfortable not always don't be
that person who is always full warm and
comfortable you'll never be happy and
that's hard for a lot of people contrary
to popular belief again nearly all of
the problems that are considered an
epidemic today are not in the United
States anyway let's separate that from
third-world countries they're not the
result of lack they are the result of
overabundance nearly all of them let's
go through a few example even physical
health right for example most of the
economic problems in the West now if you
tune into a democratic debate they're
not talking about poverty maybe some but
the most prominent theme that we hear is
about the income gap is about the chasm
because poverty in the Western world is
lower than ever and by the way it's
lower than ever with a standard of
living for those in poverty higher than
that of rich people from
the other generation of Sultan's in most
cases a higher sinner than royalty of
people from previous generations so we
hear the epidemic is the wealth gap
poverty is lower than ever but now we
have an epidemic that there are some
people of so much more than other people
the problem there is not a lack of
resources the problem stems from an
overabundance of resources and a lack of
appreciation the poor have more than
enough resource and people won't like
this here but the poor in the United
States generally have more than enough
resources to live comfortably and then
the wealthy have more than enough
resources to build and accrue more
wealth and so that gap increases the
poor in the United States are generally
not starving they generally aren't cold
without heat they're generally not sick
and cast aside for dead as they used to
be and I'm talking only a couple hundred
years ago they often have two cars three
square meals plus snacks often bought at
restaurants a climate-controlled house
access to technology that Simon Cowell
couldn't imagine 18 years ago but
they're unhappy and not only the poor
the middle-class are unhappy why because
someone else has far more than them now
that gap is real but it's a byproduct of
overabundance for everyone the obesity
epidemic we hear about that all the time
that was Michelle Obama's campaign get
out and move you first now people aren't
obese because they're starving they're
not obese because of a lack of access to
food and by the way food deserts are a
myth especially in 2019 with Amazon
fresh now I remember the used to be
those commercials from that food deserts
people in Harlem can't get an apple wait
they can't get an apple now people are
not okay let's go with what people are
obese not because they don't have food
not only do they have more food and they
need okay but they are required people
in this country to work less than anyone
in history to procure it more access to
food than ever they don't have to hunt
for it they don't have to forage for it
they don't have to skin it cure it cut
it or cook it people in this
tree not all I know some of you're gonna
say it's glandular I get it but a lot of
people are obese because when they're
hungry the food is there and they need
accomplish nothing for it and they're
obese because when they're not hungry
the food is there and they need not work
for it and so why not you become numb to
it Comfort becomes so second nature it
becomes taken for granted and that you
don't even realize what it is you have
the same goes by the way let's get back
to this the idea of depression feelings
of hopelessness and this is I've talked
about actually struggling with clinical
depression my whole adult life okay I
get it but people now who feel
hopelessness you see a lot of young
people today who feel that way
it's an epidemic we hear there are more
young people depressed than any
generations before them why yeah that's
quite do they have it worse then the
young people drafted in World War two
what about the kids of early settlers
what about the peasants and the Roman
Empire what about child slaves many
people feel hopeless for the same reason
that many people are obese the needs are
always met and so happiness somehow
eluded them why because constant comfort
cannot it is incapable of breeding true
happiness for the same reason that the
meal is never satisfying for someone
who's always full and that shower it can
never it can never be that bliss that
Nirvana like State for the person who
never sweat and bled and earned it let's
go to health care we the health care
this is another one all the time because
this is just in water doing research
watching the Democratic debates we have
a health care epidemic in the United
States that's what we're it's a crisis
think about that for a second how how is
there a health care crisis in 2019 2020
have to get used to writing down 2020
I'm still right in 2019 how is there a
health crisis in the nation that has
cured more diseases than any to have
come before it bar none not even close
has more technology medical innovation
than any other country in the history of
the world has the highest survival rate
of life-threatening diseases
was it in the throes of healthcare
crisis Oh what it stems from is people
having better healthcare than anyone on
the planet fifty years ago but not as
good as the next guy I want you to
understand and this is something that's
tough because then you see this a lot if
you were raised in wealth you know this
idea of a silver spoon we hear this
quite a bit and I've seen that I've seen
wealthy kids who never appreciated what
they had but I've also seen poor kids
let me give you a story I'm gonna be
going a little bit long but forgive me I
my wife okay
lived in a motel for a while while her
dad was starting up a business okay
wasn't well then later on in life in her
early kind of teens they were doing
pretty well her I said she should say
probably run six seven years old when
she was eight her father took her to
Tijuana so that she would appreciate
what she had in the United States my
wife is so thrifty she will we don't
lack financial resources we're not
millionaires we're not rich we're not
part of the top zero point but I'm
really really grateful for what we have
is someone who lived out of an 82 Datsun
but my wife still makes sure to find the
best deal she coupons right I knew
someone who was divorced household not
wealthy at all this is in New York City
when I was there and I had a gateway
computer this is the true story had a
gateway computer and the reason I got it
was it was a year old and it was a floor
model at CompUSA you guys remember that
CompUSA so I got it was really
inexpensive it was one of the early kind
of like 14-inch smaller computers was
woefully underpowered anyway this girl
liked that computer girlfriend this
family not super wealthy her dad who was
a friend of mine bought her a custom
Dell because she was about to go to
college never him telling me beforehand
showing me the doubt and he was so and I
Adele's are still around right the guy
went to prison dude you're getting Adele
well dude you're getting sodomized so I
remember the dad telling me how excited
he wasn't showing it to me and I had
this like matte black finish which now
you see on cars which is just god-awful
but I remember it really clearly going
and she's gonna love that and I was
there when she opened it up
poor girl and she opened it up and the
very first thing she said was it's not
cute like his and pointed to mine here's
the thing my gateway was a piece of crap
it didn't work well at all I'm pretty
sure it wasn't it wasn't it's a floor
model I'm pretty sure that the employees
at CompUSA played kickball with it it
never worked right but she thought that
it looked nicer and compact and her Dell
was a full-size laptop oh the nerve the
very first thing she said was not thank
you Dad not oh my gosh I have look at
all of this technology I have in the
palm of my hands now thank you for
thinking of me was it's not as cute as
his so you can have wealthy people whose
parents take them to Tijuana to make
them appreciate what the have and you
can have people who live in lower middle
class or poor households who never ever
learn to appreciate it why it stems from
putting yourself in positions of
discomfort if you live a life in which
you are entirely warm fed clothed and
satisfied you will never accomplish
great things you'll never accomplish
great things and you will never
appreciate what it is that you have so
this is my challenge to you this week
and it's a little more than just doing
gratitudes right I want people like I'm
gonna do my boundary box with my in-laws
and read it just know I want you to go
through this more specifically do a deep
dive kind of right now when your your
heart and your soul think about what it
is that especially if you're out there
and you're feeling hopeless or depressed
or lost I want you to think about what
it is that maybe you take for granted
that you enjoy on a day-to-day basis
that wouldn't even have been available
to your father to your mother certainly
not your grandfather I want you to think
about what it is in a day - David do you
have it
cable television do you have internet
access do you have a smartphone let's go
further
does your family have two cars do you
have heat let alone air conditioning are
you starving on any given day do you
have lunch to have snacks in the
cupboard are you able to even if you're
not a good student make up for those
grades and go to a community college
hey are you lucky enough to not be
drafted into some of the deadliest Wars
of all time
look at because by the way this was
commonplace everything that I just named
not long ago in the realm of human
history I want you to take inventory and
then take a second I want you to find a
way to make yourself as uncomfortable as
humanly possible on a day-to-day basis
that's why I've talked about this for
particularly men listen I'm a Christian
find Christ find a good wife have a good
family that's most important number two
on that list is weight lifting or some
kind of a sport that's tough on your
body
why because you need to feel discomfort
on a day-to-day basis so you can taste
victory so I want you to find ways to
make sure that you don't go through the
next week or the next month or 2020
taking it for granted because you're
really nothing more than a fat cat on a
pillow with someone feeding them grapes
and by the way hey there's another one
can you buy grapes that wasn't doable if
you were on the East Coast a hundred
years ago
your grandfather was lucky if he got an
orange in his stocking and if his dad
was a real dick he got coal so I want
you to take inventory and let me know
how are you going to make yourself
uncomfortable so that you can actually
find true happiness sounds simple trust
me it's a way to live see you next week
[Music]